hey look first of all i won't let you  and your daughter know i do this day in  and day out i know a good man when i see  one  your husband's a good man  yeah  yeah i know that i know that he wouldn't  he wouldn't hurt a spider  he has these episodes sometimes but  nothing like this nothing this bad has  he ever been violent towards you with  your daughter violent no no hell no no  he loves that child with his whole heart  that's good to know and before i go is  there anything i can help you with  yeah  yeah you can tell me why the fbi's on  their way to my house i i didn't i  didn't do anything wrong i apologize man  that's just procedural  this is my number  you do anything you don't like you just  call me  it makes sense  here's anything you want me to tell  brian  yeah  yeah tell him that i  tell him that kaya says  don't do nothing stupid  okay man  let me pass that along  you